on voulait vraiment pas que genre et
nous on essaie de parler
vous avez une chance éléments péché de
parler j'ai heureux vous avez une chance
de faire de musique
vous avez une chance de ça venir
militariste ce soir il n'en profitez pas
vraiment je pense qu'il est un peu
amènes
vous avez fait une chanson qui a fait
des chambres où ils s'étaient la chanson
les deux oncles
oui ça vous a valu beaucoup d'ennuis
cette chanson beaucoup d'ennuis non ça
m'a valu beaucoup de critiques mais ça
ne m'a jamais valu beaucoup d'ennuis je
n'ai jamais eu d'ennuis avec meyer qui
la désapprouvent cette chanson l'écho
lieu de mettre en joue quelques vagues
et demi mot mieux vaut attendre un peu
qu'on le change en a mieux vaut tourner
sept fois sa crosse dans la main mieux
vaut toujours remettre une salve à
demain parce que je me suis aperçu que
les ennemis devenait très vite des amis
on parle en ce moment de faire la
nouvelle repose à la parler à une à une
autre époque mais hélas cette chanson et
deux ans mais je crois que même à 7
notre ville natale sa bulle quand même
des embiez petits ennuis de tes ennuis
non je n'ai jamais eu d'ennuis et
brouille les gens qui ont désapprouvé
cette chanson j'ai reçu pas mal de
lettres l'angola devra demander de la
changer
non et puis la mauvaise herbe quand le
jour de gloire est arrivée comme tous
les autres étaient crevés
moi seul connu le déshonneur de ne pas
l'être mort au chaud et enfin c'est un
peu de la littérature tout de même un
fait mais vous la connaissiez aussi
celle là je vous savez j'ai écrit celle
qui me passe par la tête et que donc que
les choses qui me passe par la tête sont
anti militariste genre niger et que vous
avez migrateurs par le que c'est que
bigeard était de vos admirateurs
c'est vrai qu'on a beaucoup ses chansons
et ben oui mais oui a lancé le samedi
facile à limiter ses bras sa présence le
plus proche rosenau je vous propose
alertant de routage ou pour une toute
petite toile c'est une chanson que vous
ne connaissez pas d'une chanson hot et
de guitares ils ont les paroles sont de
bernard clavel et la musique de pierre
perret de l'entente cette chanson voilà
elle va passer là